an Albuquerque fighter was injured after
UFC star Conor McGregor threw a dolly
through a bus window there's a fighter
named partum who is conor mcgregor's
best friend habib and his guys cornered
him over some political stuff and habib
slapped him conor mcgregor found out
that he slapped them he jumped on a
private plane loaded with bunch of his
friends flew to New York Connor and his
guys tried to attack the one just simply
miss it lets me know where you can get
lost in location he's ready to [__] me
well the question is can kind of catch
him is coming in yeah and if Connor can
catch him what car can knock anybody
[Applause]
because number one is it but in like a
division
I've always wanted that for the Conor
McGregor khabib nurmagomedov true
Geordie prediction a lot of these MMA
guys they give you both sides sit on the
fence don't say who do you think is
gonna win I'm saying it now I know a lot
of you who seen me reaction to the press
conference thing I'm a Connor farm boy
right in the Connor dick I see in a few
comments here I just found the guy funny
Jeremy you can't laugh at someone in a
[__] press conference acting like a
crazy bastard drinking whisky without
getting [__] for it these days anyway
now I'm gonna make me prediction Shh
some of you lot think you already know
you don't know what you're talking about
shut the [__] up and listen are these
two guys they're like polar opposites
Conor McGregor is brush cocky arrogant
Irish whisky khabib is what's a posh
word for borin [__] Lawrence sorry that
people who think I'm ridin Connors take
over now they're really ready they type
in already but he's just sort of stoic
is that a good word
he's like a manly man wrestle bears as a
kid he doesn't seem like the life and
soul of the part he keeps himself to
himself I kind of like that about him to
be honest with you he's not trying to be
a superstar he he seems to want to make
a legacy you know he's not taking
pictures of his Rolexes and putting them
all over Instagram he's just they so
different these guys do you know I'm
saying the build-up that this fight has
been possibly the best in fight history
the arrest of Conor McGregor because
khabib slapped his training partner
autumn Labov around which made Conor I
want to get on a play and had smashed
the boss up that could be with
probably fight them in the middle of the
street that is drama and that makes
[__] people by faith this is going to
be [__] huge the last time McGregor
was this aggressive pre-fight was
probably josie aldo and it worked on
aldo i mean aldo was similar to khabib
he was cool calm had a record of being
undefeated a long time before that
and he wasn't used to someone being
screaming in his face and not
intimidated by him at all if anything I
think like he was the alpha male he was
the dominant force Aldo was so wound up
by the time he got on that cage he
wanted to fight the fire that mcgregor
brought a fight with fire in fight the
problem is by the time he got in the
cage mcgregor had water he was ice calm
it was all an act it was all they waned
I'll go up and get him to play right
into his hands and potentially we could
say the same thing happen this time
however despite me finding McGregor's
insults to khabib funny in the press
conference I do think could be handled
it pretty well he's from that Russian
fighter mold like Fayed or like ice cool
and despite him argue and a bit with
McGregor I don't think he was anywhere
near as wound up as Aldo was by that
press conference and he's gonna need to
keep us knew a lot of people are
breaking this stone to be a wrestler
beats us right now oh well then that's
it innit Jamie why even do the fight
could be go back to Russia go wrestle
some base corner go drink yeah whiskey
in Ireland there's no point Jeremy and
they've sorted it on the Internet
youtubers have done it not in my opinion
a wrestler does be a striker unless the
striker is competent enough to keep the
fight standing long enough to hurt the
wrestler and in order for us to work out
whether that can happen we need a look
at the skills of these guys with khabib
wrestling is obviously his
bread-and-butter is what he does he can
manipulate people's bodies in such a way
of that he just lands the takedown when
he really
are the first take down on Michael
Johnson how did you manage that but he
just just enough to get them where he
needs them to be and when he gets you
down he keeps you down his top game is
one of the best in MMA ever could be was
strong like the kind of strong that when
you watch him in a UFC fight and you
think [__] that guy strong but when they
get in there with him you see a look of
what the [__] like shocked at how strong
he is
and that must do something to you
mentally in there when you'd prepared
for this level of strength and then he's
three levels above that doesn't just
hurt you physically it hurts your
feelings how strong this guy is you
[__] up when you took this fight that
kind of strong khabib doesn't just end
your night quickly he doesn't just shut
the lights off like a knockout artists
like Conor does he grinds you down and
if anything some people probably would
rather just get knocked out in the first
round you know that way you must be like
right that was not all by like me he
humiliates you he talks to the owner of
the ERC while beating the [__] out of
you that must he's not even
concentrating on you 100% and he's still
on top of you owning the [__] out of you
was Conor McGregor its timing and
accuracy on the fee you go in there with
him thinking I could stand with this guy
I mean I'm good I've beaten people
before I'm on his level I've seen what
he does and then he just catches you
time and time again you're getting lit
the [__] up from angles you didn't even
know it was possible to get hit from
could be makes you look like a child
Conor makes you look like you're of a
child's level of ability
makes you look like you're a white belt
plays the skies and Samurai with
McGregor McGregor seems to take pride
and joy in taking the piss out of you as
he punches you in the [__] chin like
he laughs he thinks it's hilarious
whereas while Kirby was talkin to the
boss about his new contract I don't
think he's even thinking this is
humiliating this guy emotionally he's
just not even there he doesn't give a
[__] when he fought Alvarez it was just
a man against a boy and Alvarez is not a
boy but he is on such a level mentally
he doesn't get affected by first-ever
UFC in New York two titles on the line
he treats it like he's just gone out
there to have a little scrub in a park
somewhere like McGregor fights as if
it's funny
another thing McGregor does is he lulls
fighters into a false sense of security
he's he's working out your patterns he's
memorizing what you do and how you react
and then he walks you on to his left
hand he's not making self that
vulnerable the land the left hand
occasionally may take a shot but a lot
of the time he just guides you on to his
strengths and he can do that to pretty
much anyone
Division when it comes to weaknesses
they select it's like their
personalities they're polar opposite
their weaknesses are the opposites their
weaknesses are each other's strengths
which is why this fight is so hard to
call because these guys could both be
each other it just depends on who can
cover those weaknesses bear to assert
their strengths in terms of khabib like
he's at an automatic disadvantage
because the fight starts standing up
which is McGregor's game and in that
game khabib is basic like let's not kid
ourselves yeah basing his head movement
is almost non-existent his footwork he's
there to be here and he's not quick and
he's been hit a lot of times by a lot of
fighters who are nowhere near as good as
Conor McGregor is it hitting people and
also his game plan is to take the fight
down you you know what he wants to do
there's there's no element of surprise
with khabib at all coming yeah he it's
not like George st. Pierre who sets up
takedowns with you know stand up which
khabib tries to do but he can't really
afford to do that with Conor he you know
we know the [__] game plan coming in
equally we know Connors gameplan but the
problem is is the fight starts where he
wants it to be
Connors weaknesses or stamina which
Kabir is showing how [__] bugs or
Conor isn't a wrestler I mean he doesn't
come from a wrestling background which
khabib is awesomer and we can look at
previous fights to try and see how this
is gonna play out a lot of people when
they try and analyze this fight caught
the barboza fight because Bob Bors has a
great striker but he's a very different
strike at a MacGregor he's a big kicker
and I don't think Connors gonna utilize
kicks a lot in this fight because he nor
was that an easy tape down for a
wrestler like could be I think the
Michael Johnson fight is an interest and
want to look up because before could be
did land that great takedown Johnson was
lighting khabib up and Johnson's nowhere
near the level of McGregor but he landed
a left hand he was a little bit too hard
to close the distance on Forum there's a
good little blueprint for McGregor here
the problem is could be did take him
down he did overcome that struggle and
he did win the fight quite convincingly
McGregor on the other hand
struggled with Chad Mendes a high-level
wrestler or one who isn't as big and as
strong as kebede and Chad Mendes took
him down
we'll now it was on 12 days Norris and
Connor did have a very bad knee injury
and didn't have time to prepare for a
wrestler like he's gonna have time to
prepare for this time and Connor did
overcome that well could be won the
title against al Iaquinta he looked
comfortable he looked good but there
were windows where he struggled to get
the takedown
that's fine against al Iaquinta he's
he's a good fighter but he's not on the
level of McGregor if you struggle to get
it take time a that gets McGregor this
is over [__] fast when McGregor
fought near the earth there was a lot of
pressure he had McGregor after only two
rounds on the back foot struggling
gasping for breath tired if you do that
against khabib this is over [__] fast
in terms how I think this fight is going
to go if I had to give a prediction it
could go either way as everyone is say
in each of these guys strengths or each
other's weaknesses khabib could Maul
McGregor I am NOT saying any different
but there is a gut at the beginning of
every round where Conor McGregor has the
fight where he wants it guaranteed and
in that timeframe
McGregor can land all that people have
landed on could be and I think when the
Gregor Lance Kirby was gonna get a shot
he doesn't slip punches the way Nate
Diaz does there's not a guarantee that
he's gonna be able to take those punches
and I'm willing to bet with the way he
sits there and takes them and walks
through them as he tries to he's not
gonna be able to walk through Conor
shots and I think Connors gonna catch
him I think Conor McGregor is gonna win
this fight all the factors are there
ring rust is a real thing
McGregor could lose this fight I'm not
saying he's guaranteed a witness but the
bottom line for me is the weakness in
kerbs game is the one Conor can exploit
before khabib can exploit the weakness
in Conor skim and that's why I'm giving
him this week I've got no problem with
who anyone wants to win I'm not one of
these
he gets butthurt because someone picked
against me [__] favorite fighter you
do you but let us know in the comments
what you think is gonna happen because
I'm going to be reading all of these now
on anur don't forget to hit the like
button subscribe to the true Geordie
thanks for watching and I'll see you
later
[Music]
you